30% des stations sont aujourd'hui
fermées ou en grande difficulté dans les
hauts de France et la région parisienne
le pourcentage des pâtes les 50%, je
souhaite que dans les prochaines heures
et les tous prochains dans les
prochaines heures et au plus vite il y a
une issue qui soit trouvée à cela mais
vous comprendrez aisément que on va pas
rentrer dans une situation c'est le
président de la République qui va faire
les négociations salariales chez eux au
total parce que là on va partir que par
dessus tête
avec ce [ __ ] de vidéo parce que je
vais le prendre plus de son fils et ça
vous allez payer pour rien moi ça casse
les pieds ça deux heures d'attente à la
station essence deux mecs qui se pointe
en Porsche ils veulent nous gruger les
mecs qui passent dans l'herbe et tout
tranquille tout va bien le mec il a
ramené la barrière c'est vraiment la
galère parce que sur les voitures qu'on
a on a plus de carburant plus de
carburant non plus pour ces cartes
scolaires ce matin solvant pour son des
lignes ont pu être desservies similaires
ont dû trouver une solution alternative
il faut que les parties prenantes
prennent leur responsabilité les
entreprises et les chefs d'entreprise
concernées et les syndicats concernés le
blocage c'est pas une façon de négocier
passe tous par les côtés comme ça
normalement et après pourquoi et on va
pas se battre ben ça va finir comme ça
[Musique]
nous avons vraiment mille paquets pour
réorganiser l'approvisionnement des
stations services donc ça doit
s'arranger au long de cette semaine et
puis la meilleure façon pour que ça
s'arrange c'est qu'on passe à du
dialogue entre les directions et les
syndicale ce serait réglé facilement si
on remettait en place une mesure qui
existait jusqu'en 1982 c'était
l'indexation automatique des salaires
sur l'inflation si on avait ça dans la
société est parfaitement raison
enlevé tout à fait c'est tout à fait
c'est un gouvernement de gauche monsieur
ce que je soutiens c'est les
revendications des salariés de ces
différentes entreprises qui demandent
dans une période dans lequel les groupes
en question je pense à total par exemple
on fait des bénéfices extraordinaires
qui demandent tout simplement dans
récupérer une partie on avait soi-disant
le Mozart de la finance à la tête de
l'État la start-up nation ce matin
j'entends le ministre de la transition
numérique je sais plus comment dire
monsieur barreau je crois Jean-Noël
barreau qui dit sur Europe 1 ah oui on
va demander maintenant aux opérateurs de
pouvoir couper à distance les Box
Internet et je vois bien la volonté de
leur faire porter la responsabilité des
situations de pénurie qui se multiplient
dans les stations services mais je
rappelle que c'est le groupe Total qui
initialement a dit pas de négociation
salariale avant le 15 novembre la grève
a été reconduite jusqu'à plus de 3300
stations services restent ce soir
touchées par des problèmes
d'approvisionnement carburant
et une autre mauvaise nouvelle pour les
automobilistes les prix ont une nouvelle
fois grimper à la pompe la semaine
dernière plus 7,3 centimes de litre pour
le super simple en 95 toutes les
entreprises du caca 40 alignent des
dividendes assez importante c'est inégal
mais globalement assez important on se
dit que dans les hausses il y a pas que
du coup de production il y a pas que
c'est à cause de l'Ukraine il y a pas
que c'est à cause du fait qu'on n'a pas
trouvé des employés vous voyez donc faut
pas prendre les gens pour des imbéciles
après trois mois sans combat la capitale
ukrainienne replonge dans l'horreur
voiture calcinée bâtiment endommagé ce
matin est difficile nous avons affaire à
des terroristes qui nous visent avec des
dizaines de missiles des drones iraniens
ils ont deux cibles notre système
énergétique qu'ils veulent détruire et
la deuxième cible ce sont les gens
depuis 24 heures une vague de
bombardements déferle sur l'Ukraine et
touche tout le pays des attaques d'une
ampleur inégalée depuis plusieurs mois
les autorités ukrainiennes 75 missiles
russes ces dernières heures évidemment
la France a eu l'occasion de le faire ce
matin à condamné avec la plus grande
fermeté les frappes délibérées de la
Russie sur l'ensemble du territoire
ukrainien et contre des civils ce qui
est un changement profond de la nature
de cette fois ces attaques sont la
réponse de Vladimir Poutine à la
destruction partielle du pont de Crimée
hier un point de passage stratégique
pour amener les soldats russes en
Ukraine s'il est tentatives d'attentat
terroristes sur notre territoire se
poursuive
les réponses de la Russie seront sévères
et leur ampleur correspondra au niveau
des menaces posées à la Fédération de
Russie